dies unsere alter jäger wenn ich damit
auf die straße gehen
die haben alle respekt vor mir die
denken ich bin zäh und so oder eine
tasse kaffee und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute heute geht es
darum ich habe vor einiger zeit alle
youtube produkte bei uns bestellt also
wirklich alles was irgendwie mit youtube
zu tun hat er wohl youtube draufsteht
weil ich ich weiß nicht ich habe mir
einfach gedacht so das musste mal machen
weil das hat noch niemand gemacht ich
meine wir sind ja hier auf youtube
deswegen zeige ich euch einmal ganz kurz
die ganzen produkte dann packen wir die
aus und ich bin mal gespannt wie das von
da aussieht ich will dann auf jeden fall
auch so ein geiles foto machen also bis
gleich so könnte was geht ich zeige euch
mal ganz kurz die produkte die ich
gekauft habe ich habe hier oben youtube
eingegeben und dann einige ist ja alles
wo irgendwo youtube drauf stand habe ich
direkt in den warenkorb geballert wie
zum beispiel hier diese kissen da habe
ich einmal das erste bestellt und dann
habe ich noch irgendein bestellt ich
weiß ich mehr welches ist genau war
ich glaube dass hier oder dass ihr oder
sogar das hier keinen plan euro 600
bewertungen die super schönes nur schade
dass es nicht bei zeitlich bedrückt also
das haben anscheinend wirklich schon
sehr viele bestellt auch viele deutsche
da frage ich mich warum stellt man sich
das wenn man keinen youtube macht weil
man es gern schaut klar aber das finde
ich wirklich krass dass sich dafür leute
begeistern dann habe ich noch diese
geniale tassen bestellt can't stop
loving you tube habe ich mega ab
gefeiert für eine tasse 11 euro da
musste ich einmal schlucken aber habe
ich natürlich im warenkorb getan weil
ich bin ein typ ich trinke gern kaffee
und das wird absolut meine
lieblingstasse wenn die geil ist weiter
machen wir mit einem rudi denn hier habe
ich auch bestellt ich weiß gar nicht in
welcher farbe in weißig der eigentlich
am meisten aus habe ich dafür wirklich
nur 9 euro bezahlt schwarz 11 eur 11
euro egal in welcher farbe alles 11 euro
hierfür habe ich elf euro bezahlt er ist
auch auf jeden fall angekommen und dann
habe ich sogar noch so eine jacke
gekauft moment mal scheiße irgendwie
gibt es hier nicht mehr ich gehe
deswegen war eben nur ein bestell
verlauf hier deutsche gebt euch dass ich
fand das so nice also auf diesen ich
habe die natürlichen roth genommen weil
ist halt die youtube haben auf diesem
foto svj wie geil das aussieht größe
l habe ich genommen ich weiß es nicht
rot 19 euro habe ich bezahlt für also
david kann auf jeden fall gut flexen
oder halt auch nicht ich muss sagen das
war dann leider auch schon alle sachen
die es auf wunsch mit bezug auf youtube
gibt deswegen packen wir jetzt mal aus
ich bin gespannt und dann mache ich
bleibe auf jeden fall meistens foto
damit viel spaß weiter geht's herzlich
willkommen zurück
ja wir haben insgesamt fünf pakete
erhalten jetzt die ich jetzt
nacheinander auspacken werde ich würde
sagen wir fangen einfach mal von oben
ist unten alles wäre nice wenn ich auch
direkt was tragen könnte was mit youtube
zu tun hat um das video weiterzuführen
deswegen schauen wir jetzt erstmal das
erste paket man sieht dass die nudeln
gegessen
ok ok dieses produkt auch schon ewig her
ich habe daraus einen eindruck wie immer
weil ich muss das ja offen ich habe das
video natürlich sonst auch schon viel
früher gebracht das ist von liu fashion
store zu machen sich interessierte kaum
die sachen fernsehen war gleich eine
zeit lang dicht es kommt aus entstand
schon richtig krank annahme man using
gängen konjunktur in china vom wangen
gegenteil wissen wir bescheid
ich brauche euch natürlich alter okay
die qualität ich weiß doch ich habe
einmal damals so erwartet denn ich
glaube für maria das habe ich so kleiner
bestellt oder pullover
da war die qualität ungefähr gleich mal
dass wir ganz grausam adria schon etwas
gerne das ist natürlich nicht so leicht
ich glaube der hat auch nur sechs euro
gekostet deswegen kommt an das damit
begründen weißt du was gleich passieren
würde wenn ich hier jetzt zwangsweise
ist halt sogar hätte ich nicht gedacht
wir machen was mal kurz einmal
dieses youtube 2016 also man muss
wirklich sagen der riecht extrem neben
dem zeug was auf jeden fall nicht gut
riecht muss ich sagen
trotzdem wie sieht's aus kann man truck
oder das gut machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt wir haben hier eine
tasse davon gibt es gleich auf
verschiedene modelle ich habe einst
bestellt ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau
welches ist war ich noch mal rein da
habe ich noch wirklich doch nicht
reingeschaut und das ist das geld
auszugehen
geil als weil geb dir mal diese tasse
vor allem die hatten mehrere gute
qualität das muss ich jetzt sagen ich
glaube ja noch in euro gekostet
mai kannst of watching you tube ich bin
ultra der kaffeetrinker ich hab mir grad
hier nur um kaffee gemacht habe ja auch
meinen eigenen kaffee vollautomat davon
ist die kaffee ecke wenn du einmal kurz
rüber springen möchte ich unterstütze es
nicht und da rechts den auch schon meine
anderen kassen und die kommen jetzt
einfach könnte man hier den film über
die könnte man einfach herzustellen das
ist glaube ich die laufer kaffeemaschine
der welt also das ist auf jeden fall
meine lieblingstasse und wie gesagt
qualität ultra gut hätte ich nicht
gedacht gut was willst du etwas falsch
machen das könnte in china genauso gut
wie ein obwohl kommt überhaupt aus china
die verpackung habe ich irgendwie schon
weggeschmissen
so leute machen wir mal weiter hier habe
ich nun nicht eine youtube jacke
gestellt da weißt du diese ganzen
youtube mitarbeiter haben alle so was
eigentlich schade aber ein bisschen
cooler held dem das logo ist ja nicht
mehr original bist hier sicher ist die
falschen trifft und da bin ich mir
unsicher leute schreibt mir in die
kommentare was ihr dazu denken das ist
nicht die originale music ist ja diesmal
kommt das paket aus london kommt aus
gewann dank das ist einfach so ein
sondertraining zum trainings dingen
weißt du sowie trainingsjacken früher
vom fußball oldies ultra alter der wenn
ich damit auf die straße gehen
die haben alle respekt vor mir die
denken ich bin zäh und so oder so eine
politik die auf youtube seiten dicke
youtube ratlos das ist ein echt krank
ist die qualität auf jeden fall deutlich
besser als beim polo aber sieht nicht so
toll aus also das zu dünner start sieht
also ich sage mal so wenn nicht so hier
nach fluglehrer krieg doch jeder hat
also von dieser jacke bin ich jetzt
wirklich extrem beeindruckt weil von
hinten hat und das jetzt schon gesehen
kommen wir haben die hat hier bei meinem
rudi haben wir sowieso kaputt weil er
für kommt haben wir auch mit kapuze ich
hätte die eigentlich in einer nummer
größer bestellen müssen weil dies ein
bisschen klein das ist schon m
aber in china sind gerade ein bisschen
kleiner deswegen wenn ihr was aus china
besteht immer ein wenn ihr halt sonst
einmal also das ist bis jetzt auf jeden
fall mein lieblings produkt mit der
tasse aber wir haben natürlich noch ein
paar sachen das habe ich schon gemerkt
also in der post war ich dachte
eigentlich dass wir eine richtige kissen
weißt du dass sie direkt bezogen sind
aber es sind einfach nur kästen bezüge
ich habe nämlich zwei weitere
kissenbezüge bestellt aus versehen kann
es sogar drei brüder haben die einst
umsonst gegeben also ich habe wirklich
nur zwei bestellt habe ich euch auch
eben gezeigt wir haben hier einmal ich
habe mir auch nicht mehr sicher was für
auftritte ja ganz normal dass youtube
logo um dann haben wir hier ein anderes
ach nee das geil kommen hier steht
selbst braucht kann man perfekt in
seinen hintergrund stellen das kissen
kommt auf jeden fall da in meiner
reaktion ecke abonniert auf jeden fall
meinen zweiten kanal
alex war da gibt es jeden tag video und
hier haben wir noch mal ein youtube
kissen das heißt wir haben insgesamt
drei youtube wissen hast du schon mal
irgendwo in youtube küssen gesehen ich
nicht
der hatte youtube ist media kraft hat
auch nicht ich habe noch nie in youtube
wissen gesehen sodann beziehe ich das
mal eben
also ich muss sagen qualität ist voll in
ordnung von den länger als super kostet
guten ausgefüllt 1 brauchen wir noch
ich werde also so ein foto machen wo ich
diese ganzen sachen anhalt unsere
unterschreiben verrät was ich beruflich
mache kriegt geld wenn sie fragt was
machst du beruflich leute deswegen tag
bitte meine instagram ab und bleibt das
foto das würde mich sehr freuen
30 alex wieso ja also ich habe ja eben
schon gesagt so viele sachen machen das
jetzt auch nicht wer mir einmal die
taste dann haben diese beiden oberteile
wovon ich die jacke sehr feier also da
könnte ich mir auch vorstellen die mal
so privat anzuziehen denn warum hast du
möchte ich euch wieder alex mit youtube
instant zum joggen zum beispiel der
politik hat echt keine gute qualität
also den empfehle ich euch nicht weil es
ihr euch verleger seinen teams kam es
hier interessiert und die kisten sind
auf neues ja ich habe auf jeden fall
eine menge neuer sachen bestellt die
auch hoffentlich demnächst ankommen
diese ganzen youtube produkte habe ich
schon vor zwei oder drei monaten stellt
das hat halt so lange gedauert wenn
corona biberbrugg trotzdem hoffe ich
dass es euch unterhalten hat wie gesagt
instagram alex wie tickt auch alex wie
und abonniert super gerne meinen zwei
kanal
wir sehen uns hier dann übermorgen
wieder da gibt es ein richtig heißes
neues video auf dass ihr euch wirklich
sehr sehr freuen können danke fürs
zuschauen das war's dann auch schon
und ja frei nach dem motto passend zur
osterzeit werkstoff watching you tube
nicht nämlich ihr deswegen schon auf
jeden fall
[Gelächter]
[Musik]